george um
with everything that's going on right
now with with the anticipation of
uh people wanting to see you come back
and you got a birthday coming up in two
weeks
what do you what do you think about when
you see everybody in media is like dude
you know what it's like it's kind of
like in the nba there was one game
everybody wanted to see one final i know
you're a sports guy everybody wanted to
see the final of
lebron and kobe we never saw it
we got jordan and magic we got magic and
bird we got brady and peyton we got a
lot of these guys that face but we never
got kobe and lebron and lebron says it
was my fault because the year that he
was supposed to go he lost he to make it
to the end kobe did his part i think a
lot of people would be curious to see a
fight between you and khabib what do you
think about all these conversations
coming up to see the two of you guys
fight well it's uh
it's always a question of timing we
we've tried to make it happen
um
when i retired a year after i retired we
approached the ufc with that idea
and khabib was on board i was on board
but ufc had other plan they wanted to
did in a business point of view it makes
sense because i wanted to keep kebab
active
because they keep the ball rolling
they knew that if
it would i would only come back for
maybe one fight you know what i mean um
they rather
keep
active i guess and not taking the risk
and i understand that and therefore
that's why i believe it did not
materialize
however when khabib fought justin gaichi
and beat jason gaichi i think he took
everybody by surprise by
uh he took he announced his retirement
and if i believe even his own people
didn't know that he was going to make
that move because i remember i was doing
the
the french commentator on on
the channel uh back home
and i thought that after the fight maybe
you would have called me out you know
what i mean i had butterflies in my
stuff you were expecting that you wanted
that almost i don't know if i wanted
that but if you would have done it maybe
i would like i would have i wouldn't
have any choice you know because it's
it's like a challenge that i was looking
for a long time yeah it didn't happen at
the time that we tried to make it happen
but now it was i think a year after that
it was still fresh i was like i'll do it
you know but it did not happen and we
retire
now
what happened uh
a few years after i i i
i was offered to fight uh oscar de la
hoya in a boxing game so modify rule of
boxing match
and um
of course i'm still
under contract with ufc a few years
after i retired
so um what happened now because khabib
is retired and i'm retired so now the
ufc dana called me and he's like oh now
would you be interested fight khabib he
asked me he called me but i thought it
was strange because i never wanted to do
it and now because he called me for that
reason i was like
i didn't want to do it but i told dana
just to see what happened because i was
curious you know it's always a chess
game when when the promoter calls you
it's so that's the world where i live in
so i didn't say no i said okay let me
think about it so i wait
and i heard in the news that they
and the way dana talked to me it was
like khabib already accepted but it
wasn't true he was just going to fish
with me to it fishing see how to make
the fight happen so they knew now that
we were both the retirees so for them it
was an opportunity to make a big money
fight
so i i said i'm gonna think about it and
i i wait a few days and i signed the
media the
aliyah abdelas at dallas i came out
publicly and said hey now george want to
fight but now we we already retired
he said so it was all bs you know dana
kind of lie to me khabib then he didn't
they didn't approach khabib first they
approached me first to make it happen so
you actually think dana kind of lied to
you no not i think i know now for a fact
straight up yeah 100 100 and you feel
comfortable just putting that out there
but it's the game that's the nature of
the game that's right promotion you got
to realize he's promoting it's not lying
it's in a way of saying if i have khabib
in his mind he's thinking if you say yes
i know i can convince khabib because i
know what i'm going to pay him so in his
mind it's a yes
it is lying but i i understand what you
know
that that's how the business works and
i'm you now i know now i i you know i'm
i'm i'm an experienced guy and we've
been doing it for 20 years exactly so i
know i know the game so that's why i
didn't want to do it but i didn't want
to say no because the reason why he
called me
because dana had a lot of eat because
they didn't let me fight
oscar de la hoya so everybody was
complaining that why you didn't want to
let george fight oscar de la hoya in the
boxing fight
and and you hold him up so they know now
by saying
say he could have go back and tell the
media say oh why would i let george go
fight in boxing when he doesn't want to
fight khabib for me for with the with
the ufc so he would have had a good
reason that's why he did this he did
this it was a strategic move of his part
yeah
yeah it's always
like this with with with dana i mean i
like i like the person now now
i'm i'm retired
we've we talked about it when i was
inducted to the hall of fame i was like
now it's it's cool we can have it we
talk about the old days and and saying
the real thing but when i was competing
it was always when the phone rang and i
saw dana what i was like shoot what are
you what is it gonna come with it how
long ago was this yes off uh until um
like until like uh you're a you're okay
yeah yeah got it so but now now it's
over now so now we can talk like two
friends and so about how has the
relationship changed
when you said
he would he would call you you would be
like oh [ __ ] what does he want now when
you were active
versus now the the relationship must
have
changed to some some extent right i did
change a lot um
they know it's normal he's the best
promoter in the world there's a reason
why he's the best promoter in the world
he's the best i don't care don king put
anybody i think dana is the best in the
world can sell
ice to an eskimo you know he's just that
good he's very smart
but to be a good promoter you need to to
use certain tools to be tricky sometimes
and he did what he had to do for the
best of his own interests but i did what
i had to do for the best of my own
interests so sometimes it it conflict
each other that's why we get some some
arguments sometimes but
it's only business for me you know
so let's go back to it so if today you
got a call
is there a dollar amount that would get
you to entertain fighting straight up
with khabib if he was also open to a ufc
card like full on the same way you
fought all these years would you
entertain a fight today with khabib no i
would not zero no zero ten million bucks
zero it's nothing that can thirty
million bucks yeah i don't care
seriously yeah tell me why i can have a
credit card that can i can use for the
rest of my brother would you wanna do
that with anybody no because no nobody
and i'm gonna tell you why there is no
price for my health and i'm not only
talking about physical health yeah i
what took the most out of me during
my active years of competition
competition it was the stress i had a
lot of stress and i always told myself
because it's an addiction you become
addicted to this thing it's like a drug
winning especially winning a title
winning a fight it's
it's crazy man i can't describe
how it makes you feel but it can become
an addiction that's why you see a lot of
these fighters they
they they retire way too late way too
late they don't know when they'll they
don't know because they become addicted
to this and i always told myself
i draw that line i said after 40 years
old at 40 it's finished no matter what
happened it's 40 it's finished because i
know
that my best years are probably behind
me you know of course when i retired i
felt
that i might have left money on the
table maybe i could have stayed there
for two three four more fights maybe or
maybe i would have got hurt in the
process i don't know but i don't want to
roll the dice and take the risk i rather
retire when my stock is high when i'm
healthy and i can enjoy the rest of my
life and also
on a business perspective when you you
retire on top
you turn around you have a lot of
opportunities that opens to you a lot of
these doors might be closed if you
retire retire on a losing streak very
good that's why i think it's very sad
when i see some legend retire too late
because first they lose their health
yeah you know they get brain damage it's
very sad to see and they lose these
opportunities that would have been open
to them if they would have retired on
top it's not a game we don't play in
fighting you say you play fight you play
baseball you play basketball but the the
consequences of a loss in this in this
in this sport it's way more dramatic
than it is in
another sport for example so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]